[Música]
como era es vosotros de niños
como era la niña que fuisteis
un día revisando papeles para una
mudanza
por cierto vivencia traumática donde las
haya me encontré con un test psicológico
que me habían hecho cuando era chaval
y francamente no esperaba encontrarme
con esto
porque yo siempre había pensado que era
un crío más o menos despierto
y parece ser que no
en una de las escalas del test aparecía
un 3 y el siguiente texto tiene
dificultades para mantener la atención
lo que hace que cometa frecuentes
errores incluso en trabajos sencillos y
fáciles
no solo sencillos sino también fáciles
además ese 3 no era sobre 10
sino sobre 100
yo no sé si fui un niño con déficit de
atención porque probablemente ese
término no existía entonces pero sí debí
ser el típico niño ausente ensimismado
con la misma capacidad de concentración
que tiene un pez de acuario que casi
nunca estaba haciendo lo que se supone
que debería hacer en el colegio
sin embargo dicen los expertos que es
imposible desconectar la atención es
decir que siempre estamos atendiendo a
algo
la pregunta es si yo no estaba
atendiendo a las tareas del colegio a
que estaba atendiendo entonces
mucho tiempo más tarde me encontré con
un libro que parecía ser parte de la
respuesta digo que me encontré con él
porque a pesar de que es mi nombre el
que figura en la portada creo que nunca
en toda mi vida yo me había planteado
escribir un libro al menos de manera
consciente hoy quiero creer que ese
libro era algo que estaba dentro de mí y
que finalmente harto de esperar decidió
abrirse paso por su cuenta
y hoy sé que eso que estaba dentro de mí
es algo que yo estaba atendiendo cuando
era niño y lo que me impedía hacer las
tareas del colegio
gran excusa verdad
de niños tenemos una vida interior
fascinante nos entusiasmamos con el
contenido que brota de nuestra propia
imaginación
y qué pasa luego
pues luego pasa
la vida ni más ni menos
luego pasa el primer trabajo la primera
hipoteca
la primera mudanza luego pasa querer
destacar
querer encajar
y cuando pasa a la vida la vida pasa sin
que te des cuenta decía elizabeth
gilbert que el universo entierra joyas
inesperadas dentro de todos nosotros y
luego da un paso atrás y espera a ver si
las encontramos
en mi caso particular entre aquel test
que me hicieron de niño y mi primer
libro pasaron 30 años
es decir que yo permanecí de espaldas a
lo que el universo había enterrado
dentro de mí durante gran parte de mi
vida y aunque me gustó encontrarme
conmigo mismo después de tantos años en
el fondo me arrepiento porque si hubiera
seguido siendo fiel a mi mundo interior
pues soy en lugar de haber escrito ocho
libros habría escrito 9 o 19
muchas veces me pregunto a dónde fueron
a parar los libros que nunca escribí
nos pasamos la vida atendiendo a lo que
ocurre fuera en lugar de atender a lo
que nos ocurre dentro aceptando ideas
prefabricadas protagonizando argumentos
estándar y viviendo nuestra vida de
uniforme
por ejemplo pocas veces se ha
reivindicado tanto la originalidad como
en los años 60
y sin embargo aquellos jóvenes que
escogieron los vaqueros como icono de
sus reivindicaciones finalmente acabaron
todos uniformados porque todos vestían
con vaqueros así que al final hasta la
contracultura fue uniformada
y hoy es mucho peor hoy puede ocurrir
perfectamente que dos chicas acudan a
una fiesta de cumpleaños y se den cuenta
de que las dos llevan el mismo vestido
porque el fast fashion se ha convertido
en una epidemia y casi todos compramos
en las mismas marcas hoy ocurre que
alguien saca una fotografía
pretendidamente genial y no se da cuenta
de que todo el mundo está sacando la
misma fotografía por ejemplo la del
camino que se pierde en el horizonte
la de las copas de los árboles en el
bosque y por supuesto la reina de todas
las fotografías hoy día que es la de la
mirada perdida en el infinito como
rodrigo de triana cuando ha visto el
nuevo mundo
es más
para que viajamos hoy es posible viajar
a otra ciudad y ver la misma película y
tomarte un café en la misma cafetería
que en tu ciudad de origen hasta la
artesanía y el ocio callejero esas
omnipresentes esculturas vivientes se
parecen entre sí
para que viajamos entonces
parece ser que alguien está empeñado en
que todos seamos finalmente el mismo
ciudadano y vivamos en la misma ciudad y
eso es lo que yo llamo vivir una vida de
uniforme
este fenómeno por cierto ya tiene nombre
se llama el efecto hipster se han
utilizado modelos matemáticos para
determinar que al final todos los
revolucionarios acaban pareciéndose
entre sí es decir en una colectividad de
repente surge un rebelde una oveja negra
que salta a la valla
y alguien le gusta la idea y salta
también y luego otra persona y luego
otra y luego otra y luego otra así hasta
que todos vestimos en vaqueros todos
vemos las mismas series y todos tomamos
el café en las mismas cápsulas
el fenómeno cada día es más intenso
porque todos tenemos una ventanilla en
la cual hacer nuestras preguntas y a
todos nos dan las mismas respuestas
pensémoslo por una vez que es lo primero
que hacemos todos cuando buscamos una
idea ya se trate de una idea para una
fiesta de cumpleaños o para una carta de
recomendación
preguntar a google verdad
como hemos llegado hasta aquí
cómo hemos llegado a creer que google
tiene todas nuestras respuestas a veces
me pregunto qué ocurriría si google
dijera no tengo ni idea no sé ni de lo
que me estás hablando
quizá entonces comenzaríamos a construir
nuestras propias ideas
este fenómeno muestra de manera muy
evidente que nuestro nivel de
originalidad personal está disminuyendo
sin embargo el nivel de originalidad que
hace falta para sorprender cada vez es
mayor
en uno de los primeros estrenos del cine
se veía un tren que entraba en una
estación en blanco y negro por supuesto
y dicen que algunas de las personas que
estaban en la sala salieron corriendo
asustadas porque pensaban que el tren
era real
posiblemente es una historia falsa como
todas las buenas historias y sin embargo
a mí me sigue sorprendiendo que hoy
podamos ver como muertos vivientes se
arrancan la cabeza unos a otros a
mordiscos mientras cenamos
y es que ya nada nos sorprende
así que si en el eje vertical pongo la
originalidad y en el eje horizontal
pongo el paso del tiempo resulta que por
un lado nuestro nivel de originalidad
personal
está disminuyendo pero por otro lado el
nivel de originalidad que hace falta
para sorprender cada vez es mayor
la pregunta es qué pasa en el punto de
corte
la respuesta es en el punto de corte el
mundo se queda sin ideas frescas nuevas
diferentes sorprendentes el mundo no
tiene la originalidad que hace falta
para seguir haciendo nuestra vida
emocionante
muchos pensaréis como yo que estamos muy
cerca de ese punto
otros pensaréis que estamos muy lejos y
algunos otros pensaréis que hace tiempo
que ya hemos cruzado esa frontera sin
embargo nada de eso es importante lo
realmente importante es que más allá del
punto de corte el mundo se vuelve un
lugar triste y aburrido
quizá por eso decía franklin fuer que
debemos conferir a la originalidad un
estatus superior porque de no hacerlo la
cultura gravitará hacia la banalidad y
hacia el lugar común
no sé vosotros pero yo prefiero una
sociedad de ovejas negras de excéntricos
cada uno a su manera que una multitud de
clones que caminan por una misma ciudad
llena de escaparates cines y
restaurantes
igualmente miméticos y para eso tenemos
que ser mucho más originales
la pregunta es cómo hacerlo porque claro
con decir se original no es suficiente
sería como decir sé feliz la gente no es
feliz porque tú se lo digas o como decir
se inteligente
algunos se lo querría decir a su jefe
así su vida ha cambiado y desde luego
esto no lo vamos a arreglar
preguntándose lo a google
dejadme que os cuente una pequeña
historia un día estaba yo buscando un
artículo para una de mis investigaciones
y no lo encontraba por ninguna parte no
estaba en ninguna de mis bases de datos
así que decidí escribir al autor y
resultó ser un hombre muy amable ya
jubilado que me dijo que no disponía de
la copia digital
pero que me podría enviar una fotocopia
por correo postal
naturalmente acepte y al cabo de unos
días apareció en mi buzón de correos un
sobre con un matasellos extranjero hay
tanta nostalgia en ese tipo de sobres
verdad
dentro estaba el artículo que tanto
necesitaba acompañado de una tarjeta en
la cual se podía ver un cuadro pintado
al óleo y una dirección de internet
por pura curiosidad abría aquella
dirección y me encontré con el sitio web
de aquel hombre que tras retirarse de la
ciencia se había dedicado por entero a
la pintura
y en aquella página no había apenas
rastro alguno de su pasado como
investigador
yo pensé que era un científico que al
jubilarse se había reinventado como
pintor
hasta que leí que uno de los primeros
recuerdos de su vida
era el dibujo
y entonces comprendí que realmente él
había sido pintor durante toda su vida y
simplemente había regresado a su esencia
por eso la pregunta más importante no es
quién quieres ser
la pregunta más importante es
quién eres quién es esa persona que ha
sido siempre cuál ha sido tu identidad
verdadera desde los orígenes de tu
existencia
desde que eras tan solo una niña
desde que eras un niño
cuál es tu voz tu diferencia tu mirada
peculiar tu fuente de originalidad
sin embargo como todas las capacidades
humanas la originalidad depende de algo
todavía más simple
de una actitud
de la actitud de querer ser fiel a uno
mismo y diferente a los demás de no
querer seguir a la mayoría de querer ser
una orgullosa oveja negra que salta la
valla rebosante de rebeldía
fue robert frost el que escribió este
maravilloso verso
dos caminos se bifurcaban en un bosque y
yo escogí el menos transitado y eso hizo
toda la diferencia
si seguimos pendientes del exterior en
lugar de atender a lo que ocurre en
nuestro interior
si seguimos aceptando ideas
prefabricadas calcando a los demás
siendo víctimas gratuitas del efecto
hipster al final la copia recursiva
generará un bucle infinito y el mundo se
detendrá porque son las ideas originales
las que lo mueven
quien va a crear en el futuro las
películas que nos conmoverán la ropa que
ansiamos vestirnos
y todo lo que nos hará vibrar
la única respuesta a todas esas
preguntas es cada uno de nosotros
tú
nadie puede tener tus ideas porque son
las tuyas porque son hijas de tu mundo
de tu historia de aquello que tú
consideras valioso por eso nadie salvo
tú puede emprender ese proyecto
que llevas acariciando desde hace años
o inventar esa receta o decorar tu casa
de la manera en que tú lo haces o vestir
como a ti realmente te gusta vestir y
por supuesto nadie va a escribir tu
libro y nadie pintara tu cuadro
solamente tú puedes hacerlo
cada vez que acepte es una idea
prefabricada cada vez que te límites a
imitar o a copiar piénsalo de nuevo
porque quizá estás dando la espalda a lo
que el universo ha enterrado dentro de
ti traicionando tu esencia como me pasó
a mí y al mismo tiempo haciendo que el
mundo sea un poco más aburrido y se
detenga un poco más
yo creo que si las ovejas negras
tuvieran un manifiesto sería más o menos
este
si tienes dentro de ti una chispa de
originalidad
si quieres perseguir ese sueño que a ti
te entusiasma aunque a nadie más le
importe
aunque a nadie más le importe o si
simplemente quieres vivir tu vida a tu
manera no le des la espalda sal del
rebaño y no sigas a nadie más que a ti
si aún conservas esa chispa de
originalidad cuida la cultiva la y hazla
brillar
antes de que su luz
se apague
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]